let's talk about Jack Dorsey um and CNN
this from the hill Jack Dorsey says he
saw CNN try to create conflict in
Ferguson Timur in Ferguson yeah and I
would I would I would say I believe Jack
Dorsey is right now
can I say I witness whatever it is he
sought no okay what I can say is CNN was
there on the ground and I would describe
it as
problematic and it was Jake Tapper right
oh everyone was there oh wow there was
that who's that portly woman in the in
the pink dress
she's not with CNN in my bed no no she's
um I can't remember her name but she's
like standing on the street and then the
gunshots start ringing out and she goes
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh and it's like
what are you doing move people are
shooting guns but no um Don Lemon
reported there was no tear gas while I
was getting tear gas so I'm just like if
Jack Dorsey were to tell me that I'd be
like yeah because when the big news
crews came down to West Florissant I
heard one journalist say something he
was he was talking to someone and then
the part of the conversation I heard was
well I'm just here for networking it's a
great opportunity or something like that
wow because like all like you know I
think Anderson Cooper was there at some
point I'm not sure but uh if if Jack
Dorsey says he saw that I'd be like
that's that's about in line with the
with the uh BS I saw them doing like
crappy reporting no security just
flailing all over the place getting
things wrong and I would not be
surprised if they were trying to egg
things on because I've also seen in
other instances of protests news crews
ask protesters to pose for them that's
essentially what he's saying but then
the but then instead of the do they have
the actual phrasing up there
um because I think what he was saying
something about like they asked them to
pose I watched them try to create
conflict and filming it causing the
protesters to chant fcnn so it seems
like it's you know and this is the way
I'm reading it because it's worded kind
of weirdly but it sounds like he's
saying they were trying to pose the
protesters and instead the protesters
turned on CNN
any and this was all in reference to
Brian stelter said Tucker Carlson is
always selling the same thing in
reference to an analytical piece in the
Washington Post that said Fox News was
selling doubt Dorsey responded and you
are all selling hope and then people
were like you're selling the truth Jack
went off like yeah he's like Tim you
you've spent you know and I mean to pick
your brain about this you know you've
spent obviously uh several hours with Mr
Dorsey on on a famous
um interview slash debate I saw that
viral video I sent you that
um this morning were you were Tim asks
uh Vijaya of of the safety and policy of
safety and Trust team on Twitter
um would Twitter allow someone to spread
uh what's considered misinformation I
said would you I I so I could be wrong
but I think it was would you allow
someone to share information about
vaccines that could be wrong and maybe
get someone hurt right and they said
that's not a violation she said that's
not a violation
did not age right years ago the point
being that um you spent all that time
with her and Jack Dorsey so what is your
take on this you know people are calling
it The Dorsey Redemption Arc but I've
been calling it that what do you think a
couple things
um maybe you know Jack said a whole
bunch of really great things when I was
when I when I went there and met with
him I did he was telling me before the
show he was like I want decentralized
immutable social media on the blockchain
and I said whoa that that's beyond what
I'm even talking about dude I'm just
saying don't ban people for saying
naughty words you're saying like
everything you ever post will be forever
and I'm like you started shaming him
you're like that you there needs to be
more regulation on Twitter Jack yeah I
was like wow I'm on the other side of
that one I was like I hear Murray
rothbard yeah I think people should be
allowed to remove it it shouldn't be
permanent but um
afterwards we talked about path to
Redemption never happened and after a
little while I was like all of these
things that Jack keeps talking about he
never does that he could do he won't do
so I don't trust him I don't believe him
he's the CEO what's going on if if he
really believed in it he'd come out and
be like guys here's why it can't be done
here's what I'm struggling with but he
keeps things a secret it could be that
as CEO he was tied up and couldn't make
these moves
I wonder I mean he's a billionaire at
what point does he just feel like I
don't need to be a billionaire dude I
can be a hundred millionaire or a 10
millionaire and I'm gonna tell people
the truth I think he's probably on an
NDA or non-compete Clause of some sort
what's the worst case scenario they
assume to Oblivion what does oblivion
mean I don't know take all his net
wealth away they can't take all of it
away
why would he I don't think he's ready to
make that sacrifice but I know what you
mean but I I don't think he's gonna
that's fine that's fine Jack it is it is
my opinion that Jack
he he tweeted out so much to be said
that can't be said or something of that
effect okay then either he prefers to be
really rich as as opposed to help fix
the problems or he doesn't think telling
the truth would actually do anything of
value so he won't say it anyway so that
that idea that he's talked about before
also in 2019 because I was kind of um uh
tweet-minding his his timeline for stuff
that he said in the past about this and
his idea for decentralizing Twitter was
more than just Twitter itself it was
actually the idea of turning Twitter
into an Internet Protocol and so the
idea being is that and if you remember
the original origin story and I think
all a lot of these like Tech origin
stories or kind of like come from a
marketing department as opposed to
what's actually happened but the idea
was that it was supposed to be just sort
of this open group text or an open chat
room and that was the reason for the
character limit so that it was a chat
room that you could share with anybody
who had access and they followed you and
they could get in right
and so the idea being that it was based
off of SMS it was based off of text
message technology so that's obviously
an open protocol so if you have an
Android and I have an iPhone I can text
you you can text me we're across
platforms the idea then for this for a
decentralized protocol based on Twitter
then open source so let's say you have
you know let's say use getter let's say
you use truth let's say whatever like
whatever social media you're using on
this
um there are people who are on it
um that and Twitter that you would be
able to interact with people across the
platforms that I could see those posts
if I followed that person even if they
weren't expressly on my platform yeah
that's what we're building with our
charity well the charity that we're
getting revved up at the moment that's
completely the future of the internet I
think Jax wanted it because the protocol
and you can't yeah you can yeah it's a
piece of software that no one controls
it's just a decentralized software unit
it's just like inverted email imagine
you'd go to the fire hose the feed
whatever right anyone can host it
your account is your own website so
people wouldn't follow you know at
timcast they would follow you know at
timcast.com or whatever and then all of
my tweets and videos are on my own
website but if you're following on the
decentralized app you can see those
things I think that's the feature
because then no one can ban you you're
just in you're just there on the
internet and people can subscribe kind
of like RSS all we got to do is
is build it no it it's exactly like RSS
yeah RSS 3.0 that was that was the
beginning of the idea it's becoming
different with what we're working on
with everybody
um and I'm not ready to announce exactly
what it is yet but it's it's very very
close to it now so he teed up something
uh Dorsey in a recent tweet
um that they do have a project it's
called like blue sky I think it's been
out for a while and
um
this is the thing I've dm'd with them so
often you know over the years like not
all the time but enough talking about
stuff like this that I just I was like
this dude's just lying because he's
gonna say these things publicly and he's
like we're working on Blue Sky and then
nothing happens it's remarkable because
which sounds great they all sound great
if I if I had
one tenth of Jack dorsey's wealth it'd
be done
it would be it would you'd have an alpha
in a few months well you need developers
even even yeah I mean everybody's
looking billions of dollars money isn't
a developer you need to find the people
that do it dude come on if I have and
then you gotta find people that like
each other that want to work together
that's true but if you had 20 million
dollars to spend on the project it would
it would be an alpha within come on man
you could throw a lot of money at a
group of people and get nothing dude
it's been three years but what they need
is organization I know people with lots
of money they need people to organize
and do it
right if you are worth 20 million
dollars
you can do it Ian are you extending your
services to Jack Dorsey I'm doing it for
free baby
join us Jack it's it's it's like
you know we're trying to set up a
non-profit that has no money to get this
going and it's taking forever to get the
filings but it's been like six months
and there's people already working on it
so I don't know what they're doing with
blue sky but three years on I'm like
Jack I really don't believe you're
working on this I wonder what he's doing
yeah it's it's it's Whispering sweet
nothing's Interiors you wanna know what
he's doing here's what people are saying
Elon Musk might take over Twitter all of
a sudden Jack Dorsey comes out as this
Rogue figure who's like I've had enough
it's time to be honest and tell the
truth and now people on the right are
going to be like yeah you go Jack and
then Jack's like we don't need Elon I'm
here and then once Elon gets pushed out
Elon Jack's gonna be like okay so let's
um start censoring everybody again and
if we need to sponsor everyone on
Twitter all the time you're not being
censored you gotta do that I wasn't I
wasn't looking at you when you started
that and I thought that was Jackson he
was actually sitting in the other chair
the whole time and we just didn't know
how did I miss the nose ring
I've asked Jack to come on a couple
times he always says like yes at some
point he's busy
I'd love to actually have him talk about
these things the issue is Now's the Time
the first time he went on Joe Rogan Joe
had a huge backlash he got all these
thumbs down because Jack was just saying
garbage nonsense and then they didn't
actually get to the core of the issues
then when I go on with Jack Vijaya and
Joe they didn't I I they did not expect
to get these questions that I had for
them because they probably assumed it
was going to be like some right-wing
dude just being like why'd you be on
Milo and instead we had like
philosophical questions about you know
the ethics of the rules and the World
Views and things like this all of the
things they said they're just spinning
they're spinning a tail yeah I think
he's because he's on the board he has
like a decant disparage to company so he
can't really say a fiduciary duty yeah
yeah right well we were talking about
this earlier in the show but he likes
being a billionaire goes into it goes
into what Tim you were saying a second
ago which is that as soon as somebody on
the left who has been our enemy for
virtually their entire time in public
life says something remotely sensible we
go yes this person is speaking to truly
love them and look when someone says
something that's true we should
absolutely celebrate the fact that
they've they've said something true but
you can't just start looking up to these
people as Heroes they've really got to
earn it by showing results unfortunately
he hasn't he said I think at one point
that he realizes now that he was part of
the problem of creating big Tech he was
like you know he really wanted a free
speech Network and he did it but he
didn't you know he made some pitfalls
like with Chris pavlovski are out there
like what pitfalls to avoid he went
public that's a pitfall be careful he
made his code private be careful that's
a pitfall because then people can
control it when you're no longer there
and you don't have access to it anymore
so he's made those mistakes and I think
the great thing about Jack is he's like
been through the gauntlet and he that'd
be why he's a great interview well this
is the this is the theory that he's you
know this is like Dr Frankenstein and
Frankenstein's monster right you know I
want to create life I want to help
people but instead of create this thing
that ends up causing more harm than good
yeah no I'm I am not saying anything
about Dorsey what he's done whether he
is uh you know I I just want to make
assumptions in good faith and say he
does mean what he's saying unless us
it's proven otherwise but conservatives
can't jump on the he's great horse right
without seeing some actual results I'll
throw this out there you know I I love
Twitter right I'm coming up on it'll be
10 years that I've been on Twitter next
month and it is it is clearly the the
simplest most efficient mass
communication system that's ever been
invented in the history of mankind right
and Jack Dorsey was part of that so like
everything else I'll start I'll always
start with that he's made me realize
I've been on Twitter for I think 13
years yeah 13 years like I just wanted
to go back to the way it was without all
this exercise it's literally it when it
was the Free Speech well it seemed nice
but it was still proprietary they were
still spying on you it always seems nice
in the beginning and then they start
yeah but you but Alex Jones was there
and he was funny
well Jones never actually posted himself
that was always staff but I just mean
like his videos his videos were there
yeah but yeah and if you didn't like it
you couldn't follow it yeah you block
him or block now it becomes a great
function yeah
you want to know what all that Twitter
really is to me is I follow news
organizations journalists and
personalities and so I'll see like
Reuters tweet something and then when I
retweet a news story this is usually in
the past month or so it's just like
reminding myself of the story right so I
can go back and look for it later I
don't care to interact for the most part
I will sometimes or I'll just post
garbled nonsense because it's hilarious
how triggered and riled up everybody get
like uh gets I tweeted schools should
have religious studies because you know
great schools because kids have
questions and teachers should give
answers and the teachers should tell the
students to keep it a secret from their
parents like I just like posting things
like that
so the importance though of Twitter is
because it it serves as a narrative
bottleneck
um particularly for the West
um you can see this most predominantly
right now with the war in Ukraine that
the opinion makers and the opinion
making it all starts on Twitter so then
that filters down to whether it be CNN
plus whether it be Netflix there's been
um examples of TV shows that were saved
just because they had great you know
Twitter followings
um and from a geopolitical geostrategic
standpoint we've seen that so much of
this comes off of Twitter
um meanwhile you know to use Ukraine as
an example because so much stuff gets
censored if you're on telegram it's like
you're watching a completely different
narrative because it's unfiltered on
there no obviously sure there's going to
be bad actors on both sides but telegram
is uncensored and it's very heavily
focused on that whereas Twitter is
heavily censored or Twitter is heavily
censored and you're getting a completely
different narrative thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there